speaking of goals we begin this hour
with a young lady who just accomplished
a huge one it's something you'll only
see on cbs mornings oprah winfrey's
newest pick for her book club she
revealed the choice from the set of the
color purple movie musical take a look
hello cbs morning's team wish i could be
there but i'm down in atlanta
working on the color purple
you all know there isn't anything i
enjoy more than helping readers discover
new talent and our next book club pick
is a star
she wrote this book when she was just 17
by the time she already been named youth
poet laureate of oakland california 17
and i'm thrilled to announce that her
debut novel is now an oprah's book club
selection and it is
night crawling
by leila motley now this novel takes on
some harrowing and really important
things poverty and injustice corruption
prostitution sex trafficking all written
by a woman who was 17 at the time young
girl and the writer describes her book
as an ode to the precarious and
vulnerable world of teenage black girls
and her extraordinary empathy and her
gorgeous writing reminds us that yes
she's also a poet so help me welcome to
cbs
morning's motley and her book to the
world
night crawling
dream that must be let me say it like
oprah laila motley
she started writing night crawling in
high school like oprah said and she
joins us right now good morning how are
you doing congratulations good morning
thank you i'm you know have an
experience
i understand we are we are enjoying you
on the set so far but before we get into
the book though we want to show you this
clip a video of oprah when she tells you
that she is actually picking night
crawling for her book club let's take a
look at it
yeah and the reason is
we're choosing
an oprah's book club selection
i see you getting a little choked up
there what was it like to hear that uh
it was surreal i didn't know that
the zoom was going to have ms winfrey on
it
and then her box it went from penguin
random house
to oprah winfrey's face so you thought
you were just chatting with like your
editor or something yeah my editor my
publicist and they were telling me that
unfortunately my pub date had been moved
two weeks and they said unfortunately
and i
went into terror like what is happening
and then the box changed and there she
was
she started you started writing this
book in high school right
what grade and where did you think you
were going with it when you began
it was i think a month before i
graduated high school the first chapter
i wrote at 16 and then the rest of the
book at 17. wow that was insane it's
crazy yeah yeah i know
um so i i just wrote it through through
17 and then
signed my contract on my 18th birthday
that's amazing that is this
this story a fictional story but it was
based on something real that happened
it was inspired by a 2016 case that
broke in the bay area where a young girl
was sexually abused by barrier police
officers and i was a young teenager born
and raised in oakland um at the time
that this case broke and i remember just
like paying attention to this and
focusing on just like this whole case
that was consuming our local media and
and being really kind of taken by the
way that the media seemed to focus more
on the police department than on the
harm done to this girl and the thousands
of other girls and women that this
happens to and we like never get to hear
it in a courtroom or a newspaper yeah i
mean you even write in the author notes
that it's a reflection of the types of
violence that black and brown women can
often face
why do you think you need or wanted to
highlight that for readers i think often
the world forces black and brown girls
to
to care for others and to neglect our
own vulnerability and so i wanted this
book to really show
the ways that we can be fragile and and
how the world doesn't protect us and i
wanted to center that because i think a
lot of stories just don't and so oh in
so many ways i feel like black and brown
women carry the weight of the world on
their shoulders on a daily basis but
when you're writing something like this
something so real so intimate so heavy
um what did you learn about yourself
um i mean i had to really immerse myself
in this character's head i i learned to
teach myself that it was okay to be
vulnerable to be fragile to be soft to
grieve
and and also to allow myself to not care
for everyone else because you're right
we're forced to put the world on our
shoulders but it's not ours to carry i
mean if you were 30 right now it would
be a young age
yeah right and you're 19 years old so i
am really just curious about when you
started writing when you picked up pen
and paper or got your computer open and
and how you found your voice to be this
good this young
thank you it's so much better
yeah i mean when i learned how to write
you know i write i was writing journals
when i was five and i think that um i
started with poetry and i went to short
stories and then i wrote my first novel
at 14 my second at 15 and this is my
third
so i've been writing since i could and i
think it's just it's part of my nature
to tell stories and to tell stories that
we don't get to hear were you also a kid
getting good grades in school or were
you like blowing off school because you
wanted to do the writing thing i was a
straight a student wow
go either way yeah it could yes
what do you when your voice seems so
clear what do you hope your readers get
out of this book which by the way i got
just now and cannot wait to start
i hope that this book is either a mirror
or window whether you see yourself
reflected back to you through this book
or whether it's not something you've
experienced but it expands your idea of
our world and our country i hope that
more people think about the ways that
we're complicit in the harm of black and
brown girls and allow
more black girls to get to to be kids
and to experience ourselves as more than
what the world expects of wow mirror or
window that was deep layla motley
congratulations thank you thank you so
much for joining us night crawling is on
sale today